where are you right now John you know
what I'm standing here with a beautiful
Lake Tahoe looking over the 18th to
death over the 18th green that's pretty
special re right now did you play
already today I have not now I'm gone I
go in about an hour how competitive are
you well it's probably the main reason
I'm here and I think the day you know is
not now getting playing the NFL cause I
did that you never lose those juices and
so I think this is one this is one type
of tournament they both juices do good
fun you want to come out and play well
and you know play well against you know
you get a lot of guys that you respect
and admire for their athleticism and
what they've done in there and
perspective sports and so it's always
it's always a great weekend
do you talk football a little bit I
thought I was that like roll over with
your pies and we talked a little bit
about the quarterbacks and yeah so
there's guys definitely that especially
guys and they're in the commentary
business definitely it together and talk
to them a little bit about football
but I know that you're competitive but
are you competitive at where your
ranking is all time do care you know
when you see these list of greatest
playoff performers or best clutch
quarterback or whatever it might be no
you know because I think that you know
what do me what your competitive your
competitive and things you can control
and that's something really that I can't
control and that's really kind of to the
people that are making those judgments
and so therefore you know you look at
them but it's not it's not something
that you gets excited about or lose
sleep over depending on where you rank I
think you know in 16 years in a pally
they did everything it possibly could be
as a good players I could and then they
know now that's behind me so you know I
can leave everything else up to
everybody else should we look at the
bottom line and that's the number of
Super Bowl wins when it comes to who's
you know big not like the pecking order
of greatness with quarterbacks
is that a fair litmus test you know yeah
I mean I think that's a great a great
topic of conversation because you know
you look at a guy like Dan Murray and it
was a tremendous quarterback and you
know ranks you know one of the all-time
greatest number one one so and I think C
is one that kind of service
lucky writes into that plus there's so
many things that go into winning a Super
Bowl and it's not only the quarterback
isn't coach and it's an organization
that wants to win so there's so many
intangibles that have stuff to put all
those on the quarterback but I would
think that you feel like you're better
than Tom Brady or you're better than Joe
Montana like just a competitor in you do
you haven't I think that you always
think that you know I think that you
think that you know that's what that's
what gives you the ability to make it
through and be successful in the NFL
because you have to have that type of
mindset that type of confidence in
yourself that you know cuz it's a tough
sport and you know it's a it's a tough
League and there's a lot of great
players and so if you don't have that
confidence that an unbreakable
confidence you can get tossed around
pretty good in this league you know a
couple other things a lot of times we'll
see great players and they have a hard
time being managers because they're
always looking for the players to be
like themselves you're in the front
office could you have been a successful
coach in the NFL given your personality
or what you were looking for in a player
you know I think so and I think that you
know it's always something that you
think about I think the competitive
nature with where you are and I think
having I mean one of one advantage that
I have been in the front office and in
the personal side is the fact that I've
been in a locker room and I know what I
like in teammates I know what I like and
coaches and so therefore you know that's
how I put my team together there's
things that I liked when I played and
the guys that I were like we're around
the guys that coached me with type of
coaches and so I think that gives me an
advantage and so being in the front
office you know that helps me so I think
that that would it would have helped me
also as a head toast now you know you
know head coaches you know obviously a
you know a lot of very time-consuming
and I think you know you had to get good
people around but you know you know you
never know but he died but I would hope
to think that I could have some success
head coach but also assessing
quarterbacks are you can you not help
but look for John Elway as a quarterback
I know it's not fair to any of these
kids
but what are you looking for as a guy
who played the position as high as as
well as anybody well you know what I
look for is I try to get I try to give
that quarterback the best chance to be
successful and that get him it and
that's getting him in the right the
great system that you know fits him it's
him the best not necessarily the one
that you know a coach has or red run his
whole life but also to be able to take
advantage of what the quarterback does
best now you want to build on Motown
quarterback you can and take advantage
of this talent but I think quarterback
you mislead to be successful have to be
in situations to where they're given and
the best opportunity for them to succeed
and that's doing what they do best
were you fun in the huddle at all you
know at times I think there was always
some times again obviously there's a lot
of pressure in a football game at some
times you know it gets a little bit
heavy so oh yeah there's a different
time to go you know try to lighten the
load a little bit there's a couple times
where you know starting the game that in
all this we have a tough time protecting
and we're playing very well and I was
getting hit got in the head when I asked
him I said did I do something to you
guys that I piss you guys off because
this doesn't stop I may not make it to
the game so I'd say yeah we gotta keep
it like is there a hit that still hurts
uh yeah you know there's one I can't
remember tell you know I got hit and
Cleveland a couple times where I was in
the air and anytime you got your arms
wrapped up and then those guys took you
to the ground no that was that delay
time from the time they think every time
you got people to the floor to the
ground you knew what was coming so it
always simple last longer than actually
actually was if I gave you I don't know
a week could you get your arm throw at
sixty yards
uh yeah I think so
seventy I probably and then I probably
won't go yeah I think for one shot I
wish they'd get it there but did Randall
Cunningham have the strongest arm back
when you played in their vocabulary well
I met her
you look at strong arms you can look at
him differently I mean Dan leave Danny
Moreno had a real strong arm but you if
you look at relief a lot of times
release had determined how far somebody
controlled football Danny's release had
a strong arm and its release was so
quick and the ball got from it a to be
very very quickly but you know he
couldn't do it
you know 70 yards like Randall cause
Randall had a lot you know his release
was a lot longer and created more
leverage so therefore you could sort
farther most famous person you ever golf
with Arnold Palmer Jack Nicklaus at the
same time no no at the same time but a
treat to play with both those obviously
both those days and what they did for
golf so yeah it was a treat playing with
ball from did they want to talk football
and you wanted to talk gone yeah exactly
a little bit of both it was it was very
good I know you I took time out for us
no you got to go play your rounds so
thanks great to catch up with you again
John thanks for joining us you know I
got one last thing before I go I there's
a rumor swirling out here that you turn
down a chance to be in a Katy Perry
music videos extra yes I did yesterday
no I mean I'm just thinking that could
it just pole vault that would have
altered you into the next hemisphere if
you'd have been in a Katy Perry music
video have you been in a video before no
I have not have you been on a TV show
but how many TV shows or movies have you
been in oh not very many and not for
very long it's one of them so about the
right amount should I have said yes to
Katy Perry well I just you know I can
picture that just both in here you know
your career to that next level you know
you might you never know are you a
singer and you sing - no never have the
opportunity gap and say no no this I'm
not singing in the video I have to play
a dispiriting
no not not dancing by the way I just had
knee replacement have you had that yet
aren't you aren't you instead oh you did
have it I I had it my left knee yeah yep
and tremendous yeah the great ones had
the left knee done I just had mine done
two weeks ago
ohdid yeah yeah yeah my advice was make
sure you do all the rehab and complete
down and work her in that rehab and once
you get to that it's it's tremendous
yeah make sure I don't run out of
vicodin
okay Zach they say you take you make
sure you take that before you go to
rehab yes
hey thanks John they appreciate it you
got a great time here that's John Elway
there the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience